Wha- that's not- how does that work?
Wait, hang on
I didn't- oh my god
That's- That doesn't seem right
Haaa...ha
Wait, hang on
AAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAA
Okay, that's good enough, I guess *chuckle*
Let me put a nice, lice big red M here
'M' that up
And we're good!
Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier and welcome to Human Fall Flat
Now this game is a beta I believe? Ow
My bones, my pelvis and my legs
They've all exploded out of my body and also
I am just horrifying *laughs*
*Horror movie croaking. Also thunder and cymbals*
I love that I've got a face on the back of my head
Oh yeah, that's how normal people walk. Activate the- woah hey
*Confused warbling*
Oh did I? I don't wanna
Okay
Uh-huh
Great!
Okay? thank you
God, every time I look at my face on the back of my character's head
It's completely horrifying
And why is there an M both on the front and the back
H-hai
Hey diddly ho everybody!
Uh-huh! Am I a human? I'm not entirely sure that's how this works
Boop, I can jump, I can wobble, I can push buttons
Well that's sweeping generalization. Some might call that horrible racism, I'm not sure
Hello
Oh god don't do that *laughs* oh my god
Uh-huh
Uh-huh, will I?
Yep
Aw.. oh
Uh- huh
okay
I'm not 100% sure about that
because I don't even think that my body is safe at the moment with the bullshit that's going on with it
But I am undoubtedly Markliplier
Like that is the one thing that I can say about this
Heh, push that button
Push that button
*laughs*
That's us humans
We like to- eh
We like to pee in fountains apparently
That just looks nothing more like a giant toilet
Great
Do I gotta do these at the same time?
That's what I guess
*Heblay? Heblay.*
*wrestler growl*
Uh-huh
Oh s***
*chuckle* Oh god
Goodbye world!
Aaaa, I'm gonna miss
Nope, I landed
Wow, that looks like that train station accident in that famous picture
So, what am i supposed to be doing?
Do I have an objective?
*confused grunting*
Ok, going through the door now
This is completely utterly ridiculous
When I got this game, I had no idea what it was about
And I'm still just as lost as I was back then
Ohhh, it's a puzzle *with much sarcasm*
Wonder when I'm gonna start falling flat here
hu-bi-du-bi-dub
Don't mind me, my hands are the same color as the soundproofing in my room
What happens if I go sailing off the edge
*ahhhh of a man not really afraid for his life*
Uhh
Apparently nothing- oh! I- oh
I loop back to the exact same place-
Oh my god, the bottom of my hat
If that even is my hat
Holy shit
Ugh
Goodbye!
Hello
I can't ever escape this hell
I just want to be free!
Oh, let me leave this torment forever
Ahhhhaha *crack*
I mean, I gotta admit
I'm very strong
And I've got quite the butt
If I'm gonna be able to- shit-
Well, goddammit
Let me strut my way to the next area
Hubooski!
Fuck, goddammit!
How do I- ugh
This is such ass-etry
Alright, 3-2-1 Here comes success!
Yaaaaaaaaaaaay!
and boink!
Yay! I did it.
I don't even know if that was the way I was supposed to do it
I didn't even read what it said for me to read.
Then again I never follow the tutorials and I almost always get lost.
Hooray for me!
But at least I'm making progress now.
*insane laughter*
Ok, this looks complicated and stupid.
What am I supposed to do here?
I know what I'm supposed to do here, shut up I know.
It did say something about the way you move objects when you're standing on it
that probably would have been important information to retain in my brain
But there's not much room in my brain
I've got two faces on my body and I'm sharing all the brain power between the two of them.
HEEEEHG HEDAA
Is this how this works?
Is this how something goes?
ahh!
I'm breakdancing as hard as I can!
With feet holding on the- oh.
ah!
I think I know what it wanted me to do.
and I think I might have actually pushed it but-
hu-thethethe!
there we go, push the- aw fuck you come on.
ah! oh, I'm so smart!
And perpetually excited about my own intelligence
*porky pig laughter, morphing into insane laughter*
Ok
Come on don't fall over
Human fall down no good
Human fall up
AAAAHHH I CAN MAKE IT
AAAAHHHH *girlishly*
Yes
I made it
Surprisingly
Shockingly
Shocking to the whole world, but I made that
*insane laughter.*
Marki gonna make it
M-Marki gonna have a good time
Pu - Marki push button
Marki not pushing button
Wher-there's the goddamn button
*asthmatic laughter*
WHEEEEEAAHAHAHGAHHA
OH OH
UUUHHHH
Where am I going now
What fresh hell have I been delivered into
Oh, do I gotta put the box on the button
You know this seems like very basical tutorial stuff
Maybe I could get to the actual game here?
I'll just surf on it, don't mind me I'm not actually lifting it or anything
Hadadadadada
Boy, this works just as well as Portal did when you were moving boxes-Hello...
Friend?
*more laughter*
Markimoo have fun
Marki move boxes
*more laughter*
*Even more Laughter*
*Laughter continues*
Sorry
Anyway
Boink
OH!
I'm learning how to use an elevator
Is this just like a humanity simulator
Where you learn all the useless tasks that we as humans do
The most mundane things possible
Replicated in a video game
Oh joyous, fraptous day
Everything is going to be A-Ok
I-I need
Thank you, there we go
*laughter.*
Marki jump on box
*laughs*
Marki tried to have fun with job
But then remember Marki is in depressing spiral downwards of nothingness
Perpetually following the instructions of someone I don't know
Just going to breakdance for fun
*laugh grunts*
*more laugh grunts*
ok, I did it.
Hello..
Hi frieeend!
*laughing menacingly* HIII-Hahahhaiii!
How are you doing? *creepy laughter*
*laughter*
aaaaaaaaaaahhh
yeeeeeeees
Ok, goodbye now.
goodbye...
with my weird hairy neck and shoulders
I just um- I just realized
how hairy my neck and shoulders are.
Anyway...
huuuuooohh
mundane task simulator awaaaaay!!
boink
nope, missed it.
I'm just punching the wall in frustration
at my own life.
ooh ba bd oohp
Oh can't go sideways
I do admit
at least in this virtual reality
I got quite an ass.
and that's all I really ask for
in life
*metallic thunk*
thunk
AH SHITDaawg
godammit
balls ass
ta piece of cock
son of a BITCH!
AWW, my foot's stuck, really?
goddammit!
get ma foot outta there!
push the button
*gasp* OOHH! god it hurts!!!!
OOOHH THE PAIN IS IMMENSE!!!!
HEEELP MEEEEE!!
HEEELP!!!
I really am stuck
How the frick do I
get outta here?
I can't push the goddamn button.
Push the button! Push the button!!!!
PUSH THE BUTTON!!!!
Oh, there we go.
Never mind then
Everything's a-okay
forget I was complaining about a damn thing
ahahahaha
ok
oh decided to just do the thriller walk
you wait there...
eh
uhuh...
yeah, scoot da booty
ok,
This better be the last task
That it has me do
because good god, this is
duuull drudgery.
Ha dada ha da da da!
ya dada da da da da DAAH!
Ya du da du dudu dah
Ya da da da da da da shit
Fuck
Goddammit
Heh
Give me just
Can I
Can you
*annoyed sigh*
Son of a biscuit
And away we go
Bweh
Here we see the life of a normal Markimoo
He's really sad
and has no way to express his emotions
other than perpetual smile.
What a loser.
ooh.
Good job threadin' that gap.
Good job being horrifyingly creepy.
As usual.
Alright, we did it!
Hoorayyy!
Boink.
It looks like I'm wearin' oven mitts.
I mean it looks like a lot of more things are going wrong with my entire body
than that but...
atleast I got that goin' for me.
Headfirst into death! HAHAHAHA! HA!
Uh-huh. Okay.
Where the hell am I now!
Am I in purgatory?
This seems like a perpetual wasteland where I waste the rest of my good years away
Why is this happening
Oh well, whatever
At least it matches the innards of my soul - EARGH
There we go
Is this just gonna be a jumping puzzle?
Where I gotta make it with my stubbly limp noodle legs
My instant roamin' body
Aah - Oh! An instructional video!
I bet it's useless!
Heh bep
Anybody?
Uh-huh
Yar
I'm not high enough for this game
Uh-huh
Oh! That easy!
Hmm
I am!
*Gasp*
Hmm!
Hmmmmm!
Okay
Hump it vigorously
hmm
Uh-huh
Okay!
So... I'm going to get high by raising my arms like I just don't care and then humping the air
That's what I understood about this
Eh
I did it!
Yay I climbed a rock! WOO!
I am the bestest!
I'm the greatest
there ever was - Look at me doing parkour up this
Free running like a BAWS
Free running like I remember all the horrible things that have happened in my life
I can't get up this can I
Oh I can! I'm the best! Ok! Here we go
I don't know where I'm going!
And I don't know why I'm going there!
But I'm going as fast as I can go, hoping
- and even maybe praying -
that there's going to be a payout at the end of this road
At the end of this journey, when I'll finally be able to get some bones implanted in my body
Maybe one!
That would be great!
I could even get a spine!
And maybe I could get my double face removed
Boy, that would be a dream on to a - fuck!
You almost made it there!
You almost did that in style
Except you didn't and everyone is gonna laugh at you
If there was even another human left on this desolate wasteland we call Earth
Ouh an instructional video!
Boop!
Uup! Oh no! Ah! What!
Yarp! Okay.
Give! Give knowledge to me!
Hello? Hi.
How's it goiiing!
I know!!
I just did that! I'm already the best there ever was at whatever the hell you're doing
I know! I know I need to jump!
I did the thing
It just didn't look like I did it before!
Having no body, and being 90% jello,
it makes things awfully difficult to be able to do normal tasks that you take advantage of every day!
Literally.
My whole body is a giant floppy dick!
That's all I've got and I don't have enough blood in my body to make it - nevermind.
Yep that's a nice close up of horrifiyingness
Yep Okay.
We made it!
Hurray-ay-ay-ayy!
I guess?
Wait a minute
Hang on!
(singing to the tune of Frosty the Snowman) I see a secret - or maybe it's the way I'm supposed to go!
Really know what's too...late for Christmas.
Woo!
Heh, it just looks like I'm so excitedly running towards everything.
YAAAAAAAY
ALRIGHT
OH WOOOOO
I DID IT..oh shit, oh shi--
YAAAAAY
I DID IT
[happily giggles]
Shit. This one's high.
But I did it. I got it, I got it. Okay, cool.
YAAAY, I DON'T KNOW WHAT THIS IS FOR.
But there's iron bars over here, shit.
Fell down. Hup!
Bollocks.
I don't know if I'm supposed to be here.
There's another way down over there.
That's convenient.
What happens if I just throw this off the edge of the mountain?
Would that be nice?
Would anyone appreciate that or am I just rebelling against the system and no one actually cares?
Habe-lib!
Take that! Screw this- Whaaaaat the fuuUUUuuck?
[knocking]
Well alrighty then, that was bizarre and weird and
strangely arousing
[battle yells]
PTTTTH
Hop.
[battle yells]
PTTTTH
Hop.
[weakly battle yells]
PTTTH
Hop.
HUURAAAAAAYYYY
PTTTH
Oh shit
Uh oh.
Huh--oh okay, there we go.
You can actually climb up.
HURRAAAAAAY
YESTH
Oh shit
Hep
Come on.
Come on, you can do it.
Get a little up there. Get a little more.
Ey. There we go.
That's the stuff. Okay.
Now let's not screw this one up.
AAAAAAAAAHURRAAAAYYY
YESTHH
Okay, good enough.
Not great, but good enough.
Oh boy! Walk into the deathly sewers where I'm sure my life
is gonna be so much better than it is now
because it's already horrible.
Hurray!
Am I gonna meet a giant sewer monster?
Also known as an a-lo-ga-tor?
Can I have this?
Can I has this.
Please. Thank you.
Alright!
Who goes there?
It's gonna be the scariest thing in here,
it's just gonna be my face staring at me from the darkness.
YUP, I WAS RIGHT.
That's horrifying.
Oh my god.
[evil laughing]
How you doin.
Ooh, what's that?
I don't know what that is, but I want it.
What is this?
Is this a block of uranium?
Is this gonna be good for me to hold onto?
Also, why do I have it?
Okay, whatever, I got 'em.
YAY. I DID IT.
WOOHOO
I DID IT
I DID IT. I DID IT!!
I DID IT!!
Okay, I don't know why I'm doing it.
Maybe I was supposed to put these in the big yellow container and keep them, but
I kinda threw that thing off the edge of the map.
I dunno why I'm still here.
But here I go.
Where did I fall.
I do not know.
[evil cackling]
Uh oh.
Hey, wait a minute here.
Okay, that's the place that blocked off before,
that's where the thing wa--
GOD DAMMIT
I WENT INTO A GODDAMN BUH--DEAD END.
Seriously, I...[stammers]
I'm not...
Not 100% sure, but I'm..
I--I think..I think..
I...I'm pretty sure..I think..
that I am stuck.
And I can't get out.
Because..I believe I fell down a hole to get here,
And...wow.
I am stuck, aren't I.
Holy shi--yup, I fell down a hole to get here.
Welp.
Bollocks to me, I'm fucked.
Okay, well that's good to know.
Maybe I could just stand here illuminated in my own creepiness.
Okay.
So.
That's horrifying.
YAAAAAAAA
Okay, so I think I'm stuck,
but there's a lot more to be done in this game
and I could explore it.
There's potential for something cool to happen here,
I just haven't gotten to it yet.
So thank you everybody so much for watching,
if you want to see more of this game let me know in the comments below
and I shall play it!
To the best of my ability.
And thanks again everybody for watching.
And as always, I will see you..
In the next video.
Buh-bye!